We have a voicemail number you can call anytime.
Day two one nine two, David P., a very important
issue that I am glad to have the chance to
address vaccine passports.
Take a listen to this voicemail.
David is one of many political actually talking
about instituting vaccine passport.
We keep hearing people being worried that
they may require these things where who's
actually going to implement?
Yeah, OK.
So this is a very important question.
Number one, we are increasingly hearing that
the United States doesn't plan to institute
some kind of a mandatory government level
vaccine passport if individual businesses
want to require vaccination, if schools want
to require vaccination, if colleges want to
require vaccinations, there would be nothing
new or unique about that.
I had a list of vaccinations.
I had to have to go to college that it's just
it's simply not new or controversial in any
way.
If other OK, if the U.S. wants to institute
a vaccination requirement for people coming
from other countries, there would be nothing
controversial about that.
And also, if other countries want to say,
if you're an American and you want to do tourism
where we are in our country, you need the
following vaccines that already exists.
You are required to have a yellow fever vaccine,
to travel to some South American countries
and to some African countries.
It's been going on for decades.
I didn't hear Don Jr. talking about it or
people calling it the Mark of the Beast or
whatever to go to Saudi Arabia.
I believe during I believe it's during the
Hajj.
Maybe it's year round.
You need a meningococcal vaccine.
OK, I could go on and on.
This isn't new.
It's not controversial.
The term vaccine passport is admittedly a
new way to refer to this.
But we have had globally, depending on what
school you're going to or what country you
want to travel to, a whole variety of required
vaccines.
You don't have to get the vaccine.
You're just required to have it.
If you want to do this thing, countries will
have rules about who can go to their country.
That's always been the case.
Much the same way that Trump did is majority
Muslim country travel ban.
He could have done a vaccination requirement
or the State Department could.
So this entire issue is completely blown out
of proportion.
There is nothing controversial here.
Proof of vaccination has been around as a
requirement for different elements of society,
traveling, State Department, domestically,
college, et cetera, for decades.
And this is another one of these creating
an issue out of nothing.
Listen, if Delta says you need a vaccine to
fly and you don't want to get the vaccine,
then just don't fly.
Delta, figure out some other way to do it.
Drive if you can, or fly an airline that doesn't
require it.
If your kid's college or your college says
here's the list of vaccines and it now includes
the covid vaccine, wonder to yourself or ask
yourself, why is the list now not OK?
But it was when it didn't include the covid-19
vaccine.
It's a pathetic distraction.
I wish they would stop.
They're making themselves look stupid.
There's nothing controversial here.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
China is creating its own digital currency.
This is the first major economy that is doing
this.
We're going to talk about it and the implications.
There are more and more calls to boycott.
Yes, boycott Beijing's Olympics.
And there are also concerns about retaliation
from China.
And we now have a situation in the United
States where half, 50 percent of new covid
cases are coming from just five U.S. states.
Which states are they?
And why is it that they are so heavily concentrated
in just these five states?
All very important issues that we will discuss
on today's bonus show.
Two ways to get access to the bonus show really
easy.
Become a member.
Join Pakman Dotcom, the coupon code better.
Twenty one is available if you want it become
a patron at Patreon Dotcom Slash David Pakman
show.
If you're already a member, you can also become
a patron.
If you're already a patron, you can also become
a member.
You are allowed to double dip for now.
That is not against the law, although we're
keeping a close eye on it.
I will see you on today's post.